we are in we're doing this for real
again thank you guys for joining this
VFX stream it's been really fun to do
this over the last six weeks every
Saturday we have been here learning and
creating stuff together and I've really
really enjoyed bringing you know all you
guys together
and all of us working on something
really cool together and that is the
entire point of this whole thing right
is to learn and to grow and if we can do
it together even better guys even better
all right so I if you guys aren't aware
there is a discord channel for these
streams it's a place where you can give
me suggestions we can talk about we can
share our work we can talk about the
things we're going to learn and you guys
most of you guys probably know I have a
full-time job at corridor digital
directing shorts on the corridor channel
and you know this stream is a weekend
thing it's a very fun thing for me but I
don't have a lot of time to you know
prep for this stuff so the discord
channel is a good way for us to
communicate it's a good way for you guys
to throw down all of your ideas so that
I can look at that and come to the table
you know with a little bit of knowledge
on what you guys are looking for so if
you guys aren't part of the discord
channel it is in the description of this
livestream signup there's a couple
different tabs there I need to add a few
but there's one to call tutorial
suggestions you guys can leave all your
suggestions for what kind of stuff you
want to learn but you know about an hour
or two ago I left a little thing in
there saying hey what do you guys want
to learn and y'all said you want to make
a super scary face so if you guys hadn't
seen the video it's out there's a video
that has this face in it on corridor I
spent the last like three weeks excuse
me the last three weeks writing and
directing this thing editing this thing
working with Sam and Nico and West
and my best friend Brett to create a
really goofy like Ghost Hunters
paranormal kind of spoof video and it
turned out it turned out you know
usually I hate my stuff hate all the
stuff I do up until that last second or
I'm just like I'm just gonna upload this
and it's not until like the next day or
two when I wash it online that I
actually like can sit back and enjoy it
for real so the videos out on corridor
youtube.com slash corridor and yeah this
scary face is part of the video here so
I want to I want to be able to show you
guys how I made this and it's actually
very very very simple and I'll show you
guys here boom
floating head discovered in a haunted
tunnel ghost chasers case number one
hopefully we can do some more of these
but yeah you know Sammy Niko they're
ghost hunters and Wes in the front seat
here was attacked by this this thing in
this tunnel so Sam and Nico go into this
tunnel to find out what this thing
really is and it gets really bad as you
can see here it gets pretty intense so
let's talk about this how did I make
this face in cinema 4d you can do it in
blender you can do it in 3ds max you can
do it in Maya you can do it in whatever
you know 3d software you guys are
working on you can do it so let us jump
in together
alright so I'm just gonna start a new
scene and the first thing that I did
when looking for you know when creating
that face was looking for an actual an
actual face so what I did was go to
turbosquid dot-com and turbosquid comm
if you guys don't know is a great place
for for models you can download very
expensive 3d models you can download
very cheap 3d models you can download
free 3d models so I just honestly looked
up face and over here on the price tab
we go to
free and I believe I used either this
one here this free male head or the free
female head either one would work but I
was basically looking for something that
you know didn't look like this you know
but actually had a bit more polygons to
it you know I knew that I wanted to open
the mouth so I was looking for any sort
of thing any face that had an open mouth
but honestly none of this stuff does
this doesn't work because it's not
enough polygons I know I want to deform
the face with a displacement map and
displacement maps only work when you
have a lot of polygons and of course we
could subdivide this but I wanted to
start with something a little bit closer
to a head so you know these two here
these are perfect and the file types
they're OBJ's that means they work on
any software no matter what software
you're using they will work so I just
downloaded one of these you know there's
also a website free 3d comm which you
know it's very similar you type in head
and you'll get some other faces here you
know ooh it's a skull free 3d comm $80
skull on free 3d comm they also sell
stuff too so once I downloaded that
let's see if I can find that real quick
let me um let me browse to that it's on
my desktop here let us see let us see
we'll do this from scratch from the from
base up then I'll answer some of y'all's
questions I see y'all in the chat oh new
Kazuko up in here dude what's up dude
heck yeah new cazuca he's got an
incredible channel if you guys don't
know go check it out
super good to see you man heck yeah
that's awesome so let's see let's see I
was looking for that face where's that
face 3d models turbosquid
where the heck did I put it I don't
where did I put it I hate it when this
happens I can't I can't find this thing
I'm just gonna download it again real
quick guys I'm sorry how was everyone's
weekend going so far are you guys
following along and c40 are you using
blender are you on that sketch pad I
know Melanie's drawing a lot of stuff
which i think is awesome even though
she's not she doesn't have cinema4d
she is doing her best to follow along
and be creative as best as she can
because that is the point for us to use
this time the next two hours to create
something awesome together it doesn't
have to be the same thing but as long as
we're creating and working on our
passion that's the point right
okay I'm just gonna download this this
head again really quick guys alright
alright
cool all right so yeah let's check these
comments here how's everybody doing good
to see y'all good to see y'all
I see some of you guys have watched the
new video on corridor that's great so
yeah we're making a scary face today for
those of you guys just tuning in here
oh snap is my cinema crashing right now
anyway we're making a scary head
I just wrote and directed and finally
uploaded this video on corridor where
the scary face attacks Sam and Nico in
the tunnel so we're gonna be making that
[Music]
what else what else yeah David so I was
not on this week's VFX artists reaction
because I was working on that ghost
hunter video trying to get that thing
out the deadline was crazy there was a
lot of work to do Oh Brett's up in here
Oh what up son what's up Brett heck yeah
dude yeah Brett stepped in for Sam to do
the face cuz like basically they had to
smear clay all over their face and it's
very hard to breathe when you do that
believe it or not
so Brett actually stepped in right there
in that last minute and kind of saved
the day cuz that face makeup is pretty
intense
alright so we got this face up in here
and we need to kind of sculpt it right
we're gonna sculpt the face and let's
let's just copy it over into the scene
it looks pretty and let's get the face
to scale it's obviously really tiny so
again for scale I'll make a figure and
the figure is it comes in to scale so
that means that this person is as tall
as an average-sized person so
scale this head up so it's about the
right size that's fine it's a little big
but that is okay so now we know we have
the right scale and you can see there's
a ton of polygons here and honestly I
think it's a bit too much we don't want
to bog down the system it's already
getting a little chunky so cinema 40 is
a really cool thing if you select your
model here and you hold alt and if you
hold down the subdivision surface a
wrong one if you hold down the instance
modifier here you get this list and I'm
still holding alt and if I let go on
polygon reduction it's gonna do a thing
down here in the bottom left corner so
don't click around because you might
crash your system
anytime you're curious if cinema 4d is
like thinking and going through a
process just look in the bottom left and
you'll see what it's doing and then I'll
give you guys a good idea if it's frozen
or not but there you go look at that it
pops out here you know with less
polygons and our systems already running
a lot smoother and I think this is
plenty to work with here this is
actually perfect I can go in here and I
can say oh this is a 90% reduction we
could we could go with a 95% reduction
and you know where's that yeah it's the
less Poly's it's a little extreme so I'm
gonna go back to 90% on that and you can
actually do a cool thing where like um
you know you tell it oh I want a certain
amount of polygons if you have like a
polygon budget right um or same with
edges and vertexes vertex to using all
that stuff right but we're gonna have to
make this editable we're gonna to bake
this polygon count in so if you select
the polygon reduction and hit C or press
this little button the make editable
button up here that will basically bake
that in and we can delete the null and
the alt all you're making if I select
this model and I hold alt whatever I
spawn or select it will become the
parent of whatever you had selected and
if you hold shift
it's the opposite right so if I hold
shift it becomes the child of whatever I
had selected so that's just a quick
little tip there it's so good to see all
you guys yeah we got Brett in here we
got new cazuca up in here this is
awesome man this is awesome all right so
we want to sculpt this thing and
cinema4d actually has some really cool
sculpting tools and I'm I am sure
blender has it the same and if any of
you guys are using blender let me know
here in these in the live chat and you
guys might be able to help each other
out you know if we got some advanced
blender users here
all right so let's sculpt this thing if
I go to window customization layouts
there is a sculpt layout and it gives
you a lot of cool tools here to mess
with this model so I know uh let me let
me show you guys a creepy video because
this was the whole inspiration for this
olivier de saga is on if you guys had
ever seen the movie samsara there is a
very very scary little art piece and I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna throw this up
here for you guys this guy right here
absolutely terrifying he does some crazy
stuff look at this look at this and look
how intense this is you know you can see
there's no nose he still has his ears
but we're gonna take the ears out from
the face here kind of looks like the
creature from Pan's Labyrinth his face
is completely smoothed over so this was
my inspiration for the creepy face so
how are we gonna smooth this face over I
want to get rid of the ears too and it's
actually pretty simple we can do it a
couple different ways basically you can
use the grab tool and go to polygon mode
and just start you know pushing this
stuff back like that and in the grab
options here you can set the direction
in from Mouse you can set it to Z so
that way it'll go straight back and
you'll know that you know it's just
going straight back you just want it to
go straight back and we'll kind of do
the same for the ears too we'll just
kind of push these into the head so
instead of Z we'll go we'll go X on the
x axis and just push the ears in a
little bit and this is kind of doing the
general work and then we're gonna come
in with the like a smoothing brush and
just really smooth out the
detail so you know it's just kind of a
smooth surface so let's see let's see
there where'd it there it is
smooth so all set the brush size to like
50 or something and if you just start
going at town here you can really see
the nose just kind of disappear it's
pretty creepy see that now it's got no
nose and we can pull this out again
because it kind of dips in set it back
to Z pull this out
we're just pushing and pulling polygons
here and then you can smooth it again
smooth the whole front of that thing
same for the ears you can smooth these
ears away alright so I'm just running
the brush over that I'm just doing
circles with the brush you can see it
just kind of smoothing away it's gone
there and there might be a tool to like
spread the polygons around more evenly
distribute the spot the polygons but I
don't know what that would be I don't
know but that's okay I'm just showing
you guys the process I did for this face
so now we want to sync the eyes back so
what I'll do is go back to the grab tool
yep it's set to Z and I'm gonna set the
size down to like 30 and basically put
it on the eyeball here and push this
back into the socket back there same for
this eye here push it back so it just
sinks back there like super deep and
gross and then we'll grab the smooth
tool again and just kind of do a little
circle around the edge of the eye smooth
that out right so it's already looking
pretty creepy here we'll save the mouth
for you know what no no let's not save
the mouth let's just do it right now
we're here right we'll do it live so
same deal grab tool and you know what
let's um just grab our selection tool
here and make a creepy smile across
across this thing like this and let's go
back to the grab tool and let's just
push these points back and I believe
went on if you set the brush size to
like 200 it's gonna just get the
polygons you have selected and push
those things back and that is very very
creepy that is very creepy right there
let's smooth it out because this is just
like one polygon here and
not so chill so I'm gonna set the brush
size down to like 20 and then just kind
of run it through the back of this thing
why is that okay it's just smoothing the
polygons we have selected so let's
deselect that go back to the smooth tool
and hit it again
and it's gonna generally kind of smooth
this out and we'll probably do a couple
passes on this
it's pretty gross pretty gross I'm gonna
leave that for now we can always come
back to this let's let's get rid of the
neck here so what's the best way to do
this honestly I just kind of um I took
the smooth tool when I did it did it for
this video and I just smooth everything
out so everything's kind of getting
condensed and then I used the grab tool
and just pushed it back up into the head
so we use the grab tool yeah the size is
200 we'll set it to Y so it just goes up
like this and we're just moving these
points moving these points up into the
head looks super gross super disgusting
that's what we're going for grab the
smooth tool again and just smooth out
that whole deal
beautiful dude it does look like a
fallout ghoul yeah totally Bret how you
doing son you practice in that guitar
I've known Bret for a very long time
he's one of my very very best friends
and it warms my heart to have you here
in this stream son it's like we're
hanging out
oh well kind of almost not really cuz
you know I just wish I could hear those
sweet tunes those sweet Bret skate
guitar Tunes right now how's everybody
doing
alright so ninth Jake asks what are we
doing exactly we are making a scary face
a very scary face a floating head
because I just released this video on
corridor the ghost hunters video and
this floating head was a big part of the
ghost hunting adventure and I did it in
c4d and it took like I don't know 45
minutes to do make sure you guys save
your work please save your work so
that's pretty good let's hop back into
our normal normal setup here this is
what we're looking at I can probably
smooth out that upper lip so I'm gonna
do that real quick
I have some like rogue polygons are here
and I don't know if those are going to
go away but I think for the sake of this
that's totally fine you just want to be
maybe it'll not as intense on pushing
those those pieces back but with the
displacement and everything like you
probably won't see it so let's yeah
let's hop back in and throw a texture on
this guy
awesome very creepy so I used a mega
scans texture on this face and since I
knew I wanted to go for like a clay or
mud effect is very easy to just look up
clay or mud on mega scans dot s II and
I'm gonna load that texture in right now
let's see here all right
boom so we have here the color which
we'll throw into the diffuse and that
actually looks pretty sweet that looks
that looks awesome
we have a roughness pass that we'll
throw into the roughness channel we have
a normal map which gives us ooh that
nice texture and then of course we have
a displacement map where if you look at
the edge see the edge of this face you
see how it's totally smooth so the
displacement map is going to mess with
the actual physical geometry of this
face so if you go to the displacement
tab here and add displacement you'll get
this little node and we'll throw this
displacement texture into the face and
that looks like a bunch of nothing so
let's tweak our displacement settings
first off we'll set the resolution to 4k
and we will set our mid level to 0.5
that basically means so the black points
are getting pushed down and the white
points are getting pushed up right you
can see this image here right anything
that's black is getting pushed up
anything that's white gets pushed down
or the opposite but setting the mid
level to 0.5 make sure you're right in
the middle so things are going down as
much as things are going up versus if
you're your mid level was at the bottom
everything's just going up if that makes
any sense for you guys and just a quick
tip if you select any of the black and
white image textures you have here like
the roughness and the displacement and
you set the type to float you're gonna
save on a little bit of RAM so I always
do that so I think 10 centimeters of
dispersion is too much so let's just set
that to 5 and already you're getting
like a creepy disgusting looking muddy
face here which is totally what we're
going for
I think this is looking awesome already
and I don't even need to mess with the
with the mapping of the texture here
because I think that looks this is
looking pretty great okay next up let's
do the eyes so honestly all I did was I
downloaded an eyeball model in material
from turbosquid calm and it basically it
just ended up being like little spheres
so I'm gonna make a sphere and I'm going
to move it into the eyeball here scale
this thing way down and I think just
setting it to like black was was really
creepy
and I liked that a lot so I think I'm
gonna do that again and I really like
kind of push it back into there
yeah
this is this is creepy I like this
and I'm just kind of messing with this a
little bit pushing and pulling these
fears forward and back to see what gives
me the best looking effect here this is
fine for now
let's make a new material new octane
material you can just go to materials
here and make a glossy material and
let's throw that down on the eyeballs
both of those and if I set the color of
these things that diffuse to black let's
see let's see why they're not working
perfect yeah okay so I'll set the color
here just a zero I think that's gonna
give a creepy look when you shine a
light directly at this thing so let's
see let's set up some lighting okay
let's see if we can't set up some creepy
lighting so we have this set up right
I'm just using an HDR eye with with HDR
I link from greyscale gorilla and
they're just the best those guys like
that's how I learned cinema 4d is
through greyscale gorilla so yeah sorry
I'm screwing these little comments here
guys thank you guys for joining I really
appreciate you all blender versus c4d
well blenders free but I love sea 40 so
I'm using sea 40 right now I think it's
super fun honestly whatever works for
you guys the amount of detail and
technicality that goes into this
surprises me every single time
awesome awesome yeah I mean 3ds super
cool you can do literally anything you
want as long as you can technically do
it and if you like if you spend the time
to follow tutorials and watch tutorials
you guys are gonna get to the point
where you can literally do anything you
want you can do anything you want in 3d
if you know how to do it that is the
coolest part so for me as a director and
a writer I am not limited in the in the
stories I want to tell because you know
if I have to do something that has a
super creepy floating vase I can do it
you know or if you put if you want to do
a story about lava all over your
apartment you can do it that's the best
part so let's keep going here this face
is gonna come together pretty quickly
and I'm just messing with the eyes a
little bit more
all right so let's set up the lighting
I'm going to let's see I'm gonna take my
octane sky here the HDRI and I'm gonna
switch it from an image-based deal to
just the color on the left here so if I
click that it'll be just the color I'm
gonna set this to black so now you can't
see anything because there's no light
it's just shrouded in darkness and I'm
gonna make an octane area light here
move it up push it back so it looks like
a flashlight and it should be shining
right at this thing and I want to show
you guys a cool trick so I'm just gonna
make four just to set to show an example
I'm gonna make a plane and I'm gonna put
it behind this head and this is a really
cool way to get realistic lighting super
realistic lighting why is it oh there we
go so you see how this light here is
visible in the viewer if you click the
light tag and go to visibility you can
uncheck camera visibility when you see
how this light is just blasting this
background right there's no shape to the
light it's just a you know it's a light
panel just a box but what if we want it
to be like a flashlight or a spotlight
or a cone light or you know have some
really cool like a headlight looking
kind of deal well you can do that with
an IES profile and you can find free
ones online all you have to look up is
IES profiles free IES profiles on Google
and you'll find some cool ones I might
even just add it to the description of
this video once we're done streaming
here but basically all you want to do is
you go to main right in your your area
light tag and you click a es it's going
to go away because what it's doing isn't
asking you it's looking for a profile so
if you go to light settings and you
click the distribution it says there's
an image texture and loaded in here if
you click that box
you can see here it's looking for
filename is error loading textures
because there's nothing there so if we
click this little ellipsis here we're
going to load in IES profile and these
IES profiles basically if you guys can
see here they're just different light
shapes right different ways the light
realistically are is like I don't know
what's the best way to explain it you
know each light has a shape and a very
it's a very yeah here's a good example
like this one and notice how you see how
like the the light profile changes it's
a circle now if I scale this up or maybe
we have to scale it down you can see
this light shape it's like a couple
different rings of light yeah let's turn
the power up to 200 let's go 500 just
cuz and you can really really see the
shape of this light and I can switch
this out this IES profile out for
different shapes this one's like a high
beam flashlight and this is the one I
used for the video alright so we'll just
use this as an example for now I'm gonna
come in here and I'll get rid of this
this plane because that just gave you
guys a little example of how the light
was bouncing off and the first thing and
I'm seeing here I I definitely want this
face to be shiny and gross so how do we
do that well let's go into that mud
texture we made
and let's go to node view I'd really
love working in node view and it's going
to be kind of like a roughness or a
specular thing and right now this
technically is reflective but it's not
reflecting anything because you know
it's just an empty void it's surrounded
in black and it has one light in front
of it but we what we want is to have
those little glistening specular
highlights on the front of the face from
the flashlight right so the roughness
material right here it's it's
distributing the specular highlights and
kind of spreading them around the face
so if we get rid of this oh god that's
why you save your work guys that's why
you save your work but hey that's a good
chance to go to the comments here
roben asks any tips for indie filmmakers
like me yes get out and film a video
with your friends use your phone it's
free it's easy what making videos isn't
easy but it's very fun and if I were to
give you any advice any more advice
would be to write stuff please write to
stuff because one writing is very
difficult but can also be very very fun
and if you can become a good writer even
a competent writer or just someone who
understands like oh the story needs to
work like this and you've executed an
idea to actually filming it and you can
even edit it on your phone with iMovie
just make little vine videos if you have
to and and I know vine is like what
whatever Instagram videos tik-tok videos
whatever you can cut it on your phone
and you know just get out there and do
it just get out there and have fun if
you have a stupid silly idea with your
friends just try filming it you know
just try filming it and if you can mess
with blender which is free then really
you can do cool crazy ideas then because
now you have a program that's free that
allows you to do you know wilder things
so I'd say yeah don't worry about the
equipment you know you have a lot of
stuff at your expose 'el so let's keep
going with this face here we were taking
out the roughness channel and you can
see how you get these little fireflies
these little specular fireflies that's
not quite what we're looking for so one
thing I know that's happening is the
normal map and the displacement map
they're spreading out the roughly
reflection across the whole thing
so let's even take out the normal map
and you see that you know automatically
the highlights start to get more defined
and if we even take out the displacement
then you know this thing just looks like
a ceramic or not ceramic but um you know
some like porcelain
or something so you guys can see when we
start plugging the displacement in how
it starts to affect this and same for
the normal how it starts to affect it
and if we just take out the displacement
I wonder what it look like
yeah pretty creepy so let's just start
like walking down the amount of the
displacement in the normal map so I'll
set the height on displacement to two
maybe three point five because you still
want the edges to be kind of rough and
then we can take the power of the noise
down to 0.5 or the normal map to 0.5 and
that's starting to give us a vibe here
and if we go if we plug our roughness
back in you can really see how that just
spreads it around the image and it's too
much
so let's crunch down this image here
with a gradient map and this is
basically like a levels adjustment in
you know Photoshop or Premiere or
whatever you guys use and what happens
if we slide the white slider towards the
black slider I think it gets more washed
out what if we do the opposite gets more
defined okay so that's a bit much what
if we just start to crunch these in
towards each other
that actually feels pretty nice that
looks kind of muddy and wet and gross
awesome
the brown is a little too Brown so I'm
gonna throw a color correction node
right in between there and just bring
the saturation to like point to and the
gamma to two point two is a bit much
let's go like mm point eight want to
give it like a muddy look or like clay
you know its saturation point five
something like this
now switching between path tracing and
direct lighting is I'm gonna do much
here because we're not bouncing light
around too much path tracing is you're
gonna bounce light around here I'll show
you I'll show you the difference so if
we have the face selected gonna hold
ctrl and make a we'll make a plane and
we'll rotate this 90 degrees and just
move it over and you see how the light
is bouncing from this plane if I made a
new material and threw it on plane and I
changed the color of the material to I
don't know
blue you can see how it's bouncing blue
onto the side of the head now if I
switch to DL actually it does very very
it looks very similar but if I started
to like you know build a little little
wall around this guy
what's gonna happen with path tracing is
it's going to bounce this light around a
lot more accurately direct lighting see
what will check the difference here if
we go to compare store render buffer and
then we switch to direct lighting you
can see the difference between the two
one of them actually bounces the light a
lot more realistically whereas the other
it's a bit more it's not as render
intensive right but it's also not as
accurate so it's a trade but for this I
think we can use DL direct lighting
because we're not gonna be bouncing that
much light you know what I mean we're
just not save your work make sure you
guys save your work hopefully everyone's
doing well
all right so that's feeling pretty good
to me we can bring the light down even
more or honestly walk it in closer and
scale it down a little bit more and like
walk it right up to this thing that
looks pretty creepy
so let's um let's add some teeth I
basically did the same thing I went to
turbosquid I downloaded free teeth so
let's bring those guys in um let's see
let's see where would those be teeth
leave these little guys look at these
teeth I don't need the gums so I will
select the gums and delete those I just
need these teeth so I'm gonna copy these
into the floating head model let's uh
let's zoom out here and just move these
up to the head I'm hitting s to snap the
viewport to the model I have selected
hitting are clicking holding shift to
rotate and shift will snap your degree
change there I'll bring these down put
them into the mouth here oh my god looks
like what's that dude from silent erna
from Resident Evil kind of gives me
those vibes
and we'll just kind of adjust the teeth
a little bit
he's got that freaking uh that underbite
like crazy right now and I'm not a fan
of the facial expression he looks just
kind of worried it doesn't look that
scary but we'll fix that we will fix
that so let's do a thing let's do a
thing with the teeth real quick this is
a cool little trick so I'm gonna do a
just make it a fuse material and octane
it I'm going to drop that on to the
teeth holding ctrl and dragging to
duplicate and let's go into that texture
okay we'll hop into our node editor and
let's do a thing here so let's have the
teeth be kind of like an off-yellow so
I'm gonna click the color tab here go to
yellow just kind of have it be kind of a
gross yellow color and the light is
really bright right now so it's making
it difficult to see the yellow in your
camera if you have a little camera here
you can spawn an octane camera by going
objects octane camera or you can just
make a camera up here right click it go
to see 40 octane tags and throw an
octane camera down on that guy so let's
see the teeth are kind of yellow but
it's really bright right now so if we go
into the camera tag you can bring the
high light compression up I had it up
already let's just take the light
intensity down a little bit
a little bit more all right and let's
zoom in here to see what we're doing
with these teeth these frickin like
Chiclets go back into the material node
editor okay and I'm gonna use the render
region here just so we're seeing the
teeth and saving on render juice because
if you can move faster why not right
okay so I'm gonna use the dirt modifier
this little dirt node here and this
thing is awesome we used it in the tank
texture tutorial but if you drag this
into diffuse you'll see first off you'll
see the teeth turn white because the
dirt map if you solo it is just the
white it's a black and white image that
you're gonna be plugging in here and if
we take the strength and go to ten
you'll see what it's doing it's
basically making the edges dark and
anything you know it that isn't an edge
its remaining white I mean if you take
the radius up to like three you can
really start to kind of walk that in
right take the radius to ten and then if
you want to make it more contrast II you
can throw a gradient in between that and
just like you would with levels crunch
this down and it's not doing anything
because we have our dirt node so load
and there you go you can see right here
how there's some darkness and grossest
in the crevices of the teeth but the
front of the teeth can remain a bit
brighter right so what can we do with
that
well what if we wanted to have our teeth
still be yellow how would we do that so
actually you could just take the white
node here double click that and make
that be the off yellow and that'll kind
of do the same deal and you can take the
black and instead of just black
it could be like a dark brownish gross
Brown kind of feeling here
yeah something like that and personally
like since for the video you're not
gonna be seeing these teeth super close
up it doesn't need to be super detailed
so that could be enough you know so the
dirt map but using the dirt map to kind
of get some really nasty gross teeth
going but let's work on this mouth not a
fan of the mouth right now
so before we do that let's just hide
this this light you can either turn it
off but that's no fun cuz you can't see
your model if you go to this little top
circle click it once it turns green that
means it's always on no matter what if
you click it twice it'll disappear in
just the viewport right so you don't
have to see that outline doesn't get in
your way anymore but let's let's make
this mouth a lot worse let's select the
face and go back to our sculpt layout
here and really push this to the max so
I'm going to grab the grab tool here and
I'm going to set the direction to Z and
I'm just gonna push this back and really
have this smile creep all the way up
into this into the face here just have
this twisted twisted smile yeah that
feels better already and then instead of
a overbite or underbite let's give them
more like it's kind of just bring the
chin back so I'll take the size of this
thing back up
yeah that feels better that's way
creepier that's way creepier and I'm
gonna smooth it out just a little bit
just a little bit because when you
smooth it it kind of gets rid of the
hole here then I'm gonna push this mouth
back even more guys and if you guys find
this view a little difficult to see you
can switch between your display modes
with n a and B and C or nd and it just
kind of changes the lighting a little
bit it'll turn off the wireframes but I
think in this case the wireframe makes
it a little easier to see but whatever
this is manageable pushing that back
let's push it let's go to Y and let's
push let's push it up too so we there's
a bit of like make some room in this
mouth we'll push this up and then we'll
grab this and push this down I'm just
trying to make some space back here and
then once again we'll smooth out
awesome
okay let's go back to our normal view
here how's everybody doing
roben can I suggest the VFX shot for you
to do absolutely yes please that's the
point of this thing exceptional asks
what headphones of these these are the
treks air aftershocks bone conduction
headphones these things are the best
freakin love them so much you can still
hear but you got your music going at the
same time I'm listening to that ambient
playlist I got set for you guys you can
check it out in the in the description
of this livestream all right so let's
reset the teeth a little bit
I'm just going to scale the teeth this
way yeah that's that's pretty disgusting
same for the bottom teeth I'm gonna
scale them on the x-axis and just kind
of push them back a little bit because
we push the chin back rotate it up so
we're getting the teeth in the back
kinda looks like a really really rough
ninja turtle like if a ninja turtle just
like stayed in the sewer for a little
too long
let's go back to the gradient I'm just
gonna adjust the color of the the dirt
here again
there we go all right so one thing I
want to do is make the well okay I want
the eye sockets and the mouth to be
darker than you know the skin here I
wanted to look more sunken so I think we
might actually be able to employ the the
dirt node technique to darken up the
crevices here on the face so let's try
that I didn't do that for the original
face but let's see what happens so we
want to use the dirt node we'll drag
that guy in and we'll attach it to the
diffuse okay and let's set the strength
to 10 and oh my god that already looks
super gross let's take the radius up to
like 3 centimeters
oh god that's terrifying 5 centimeters
and then let's throw a gradient in front
of that and just turn up the white but
also turn up the black so we're just
adding contrast to this oh that's
horrible that is horrible what if this
thing was under your bed what would you
do that is awesome okay so that's our
dirt map right that's what we're gonna
use to darken up the color so we have
that but we also have just the normal
color right so how do we combine those
very very simple so you're gonna use a
multiply node here we'll grab the
multiply and it asks for texture 1 & 2
and it's the same thing as like when
you're in After Effects and you have a
black and white image that is like your
ambient occlusion pass
and you're gonna set it to multiply and
it's going to get rid of all the white
stuff but leave the black stuff which is
exactly what we want what we want here
so we'll pipe the dirt node into texture
one and then we'll pipe the the mud
diffuse color into texture two and then
we'll put that whole thing in to
multiply and oh my god that looks
horrible oh geez I am sorry
people because that is looking rough but
that's kind of what we're going for
that's wonderful that is wonderful all
right so let's um what should we do next
what should we do next here I'm gonna
take the brown here and I'm gonna just
mess with the color of this thing so I'm
gonna do like 0.25 saturation and take
the gamut of like 0.8 to make it a
little brighter yeah something like that
and mess with the teeth a little bit
and my favorite part is coming up here
my absolute favorite part and that is
adding hair
I think the hair really makes it super
creepy so let's select the face and we
will go to our polygon selection and
let's go up here and just give it like a
super creepy like some side hair right
you get a little bit of side hair going
across the top on the other side right
here boom it's kind of like the Indiana
Jones skeleton and we'll give it some
some back hair back here you know
balding in the front the george costanza
something like that right that's where
we want the hair to be and with the
those polygons selected all we have to
do is go to simulate hair objects and
add hair and rat right out the gates
this dude has seen some things here um
okay let's um let's just cut the length
down from the hair so I have select the
hair and let's just do like twelve for
the length and if you hit if you pause
our render and you hit play the hair it
will just drop and unpause it and you're
gonna have yes I'm pretty rough-looking
here on this thing but let's tweak it
fortunately hair is really easy in c4d
so if I select the hair material lets go
in here and start tweaking some things
so if I do like let's leave the color
for now
specular we'll leave for now the
thickness so I did these are like
freakin playdough strands so let's take
this down to like point one
even less 0.01 and 0.001 so they're very
very fine and I'm just gonna render
region here so we can move along a
little faster and it's too straight so
we need some frizz let's add some frizz
okay so that's it's still very straight
but it is curling out so that's cool
what about kink what is let's turn off
frizz and let's see what kink does that
is great okay that's great
that is starting look creepy because it
looks like straw gross and like unkempt
and just nasty we're starting to get
there so we know with that we know we're
gonna want some of that we know we're
gonna want some of the frizz as well so
you have both and what about density
what is density do probably does
something but I don't know what it does
what about clump oh okay so clump is
gonna clump the hair together that's
cool
so frizz you could combine all these
together let's keep going what does bend
do very very subtle what about curl whoa
well yeah that that that adds a lot
I think the curl is a bit too intense so
I wonder let's see ammount 2000 so it
curls 20% of the hair what if the curl
is 20 degrees just a little bit random
direction ooh that's good
that's not bad and then what about
twists just going through all these to
see what they do wave not much
and straighten all right so I like kink
I like frizz clump is nice um a little
bit of curl and I wonder what's if some
of them have like some of the hair
strain so that's like I'm pretty creepy
maybe we take the hair count if you go
to the hair modifier up here take the
count down to like 500 Oh weird oh it
resets the dynamics okay so I'm gonna
pause this drop the hair again and
re-render your scene okay um let's mess
with the frizz and the kink here 50
percent what does that look like okay
frizz 75 percent yeah it's disgusting
that is disgusting specularity let's
crank those up so the hair has a bit of
specular highlight to it and let's
adjust the color if we just went with
like a like white or just gray
that's pretty nice or if it was like jet
black you may not be able to see it oh
geez
that is pretty rough guys what happened
to our teeth what happened our teeth oh
there we go
alright how's everybody doing this is
pretty intense here so yeah we just
modeled this creepy face we use the dirt
map to fill in the darkness and the eyes
in the mouth we use the dirt map to
dirty up the teeth it could still be a
little bit dirtier we added some hair to
this thing pretty quickly pretty easily
and it's fully dynamic we used a mega
scan sessi texture a mud texture and we
use this placement to change you know
really add a bunch of detail to this
face that we sculpted down into this
position here okay yeah I wish the
render viewer was cleaner to see all
that detail yeah it's um I miss this
thing's look I'm freaking gross man like
I'm just gonna at that sit here for a
second we can make a really scary scene
with this and I think it'd be wise to do
that since we're here right roben asks I
would really like to see a bullet 3d
model spinning out from a gun with some
smoke effects and all our stuff okay
fair enough fair enough so Robin if you
go to the discord server
that I've set up and go to tutorial
suggestions if you drop that there
people can upvote on that and I'll
actually be able to see it like because
I obviously I see your comment here but
at least in the discord channel it's
more organized and I can reference it
and look back at it
[Music]
vaguer tasks if I ever used blender uc40
better or more professional what do you
consider be a professional 3d program
well I've never used blender but I know
it's amazing and don't get down that
it's free oh it's free so it must not be
as good nonsense that's craziness
blender is incredible you can do some
really really cool stuff with it what do
I consider a professional 3d program I
guess that depends right because there
are some VFX houses that use they just
use Maya because Maya actually you can
tab between different departments pretty
easily like there's a modeling
department a texturing Department and
animating Department a lighting
department and like a rendering
Department and my I've only used Maya
for like three months but as far as I
understand it sets it up in a pretty
like linear easy way to work with c4d is
awesome because it has everything in one
and there's a lot of people on Instagram
a lot of graphic artists that use c40
and that's just them it's just an
individual just like myself and 3ds max
honestly is pretty old it was what I
I've used 3ds max for like 6 or 7 years
and I ended up switching back to cinema
4d which was my first 3d software but
you know that's honestly just because
the guys at max on reached out and
offered us the program so like yeah
absolutely why not let's do that it's
really up to you some might consider
blender or c4d not a professional
software because it may not be that easy
to work with a giant group of people but
I'd still say that's nonsense you know
whatever works for you
if blender is free accessible and easy
to use there's a ton of tutorials out
there then please use blender you don't
have to use c40 you don't have to use
Maya or 3ds max or whatever you know oh
my is free for students that's cool I
didn't know that
sweet is there gonna be a ghost chasers
part - I am planning on it yes I really
hope so I really really hope so and it
depends on how the video does again this
head is from model this face from or for
I modeled this face for a video I wrote
and directed on corridor about a group
of ghost hunters that go out and find a
floating head in the sewer and this is
you know this is basically what they
find in the sewer super creepy but let's
do something gross right now let's do
something gross right now okay I have an
idea I have an idea let's take let's
take this head and let's put it on a
stake and duplicate it a whole a whole
bunch and add some fog and call it a day
alright how does that sound guys pretty
brutal I know I'm sorry
ah that is terrifying that is terrifying
so the stake I'm gonna go to mega scans
just because I you know call it call it
a positive thing called a negative thing
but I am very detail-oriented I think
it's both I think it's good and bad it's
good when detail counts it's bad when
you have to rush something out so let's
just look up like a stick
alright I'm on quick silmido scans I'm
looking up a stick and actually they
just redid their website let's go to 3d
assets and let's look up wood and this
is basically what I'm looking for right
here but these look really tiny for some
reason and yeah there's like a scale
there's a scale thing but you know this
is this is perfect actually you can see
the scale
it's almost as tall as a person so we
can duplicate this a million times
wow that's a really thick pole there
okay here let's um let's just see what
else they have
I think that's gonna be what we need
that's basically what we need yeah let's
do it
all right I'm gonna log in I'm gonna
download this thing throw this head on
that stake and duplicate it a whole
bunch of times
add some fog maybe throw down like a mud
texture on the ground a wet mud deal and
put it in like an overcast situation
it's dark it's brutal but hey we're
going there we're doing it all right all
right all right so do you guys is
anybody on the ambient music for VFX and
editing playlist right now cuz I sure AM
right here in the headphones if you guys
liked it let me know let me know it's
very peaceful very atmospheric and good
for creating you know stuff I like to
write to ambient music it helps me a lot
so that's why I have it
all right so I'm gonna bring in that
object here and it's just a stick
nothing too special about it right now
and I'm using HDR I linked to quickly
load an HDR eye material here okay
I'm gonna make a new material and apply
it to the stick go in here and I'm gonna
start throwing on the different texture
assets we need to build the stick out
and you guys you guys know we've done
this a whole bunch before right
so I'm gonna drag those images boom into
the material area here we have the three
main ones we have the color alright that
does our color we have our normal which
gives us the detail and then we have our
roughness which gives us the appropriate
specularity and highlights and that's
basically it
look at that that's a stick and that's
what we need so save that we will let's
um let's set up our scene first with the
sticks and everything in the mud and
then we'll add the heads last so for a
placeholder we have a person okay we'll
take the stick and we're gonna go if we
use the axis Center tool if you hit
shift C and type in axis center
basically what you're doing is you're
moving the axis to the bottom of the
stick right you can see how it's in the
middle but we want it at the bottom so
I'll just drop the Y down to zero and
execute and there you go
and we can use let's see if we go to the
let's actually make a sphere let's scale
it down this is gonna be our head
placeholder or rather I'm sorry I'm
jumping all over the place aren't I
I'll make this figure editable and just
grab the the face off of this thing
where is the head at there it is so grab
that delete everything else
and we'll put that on the stick for now
it's gonna be our placeholder and we'll
Center the axis with the axis Center
tool I'm gonna drop that down boom right
on top we'll group those together group
objects alt G and once again we will
move the axis to the bottom of this Daly
here boom okay so we got that and then
now we want to distribute it across an
area so let's make a plane let's scale
the plane up and push it back a little
bit and let's do a thing here if we
select our steak let's do a we can do
this a couple different ways we can use
octane and do it with an octane scatter
or we can just do it in C for D if
you're gonna do the C for D way
basically all you're gonna do is go to
mograph hit cloner drop your steak into
the cloner you can see it's scaling it
or it's cloning it up mode is set to
linear let's set mode to object and what
it's looking for an object to copy this
model across right here right so if we
drag the plane into the object tab you
can see how the stick and the head gets
distributed across this plane but
obviously that's wrong right we want
them standing up so we'll select our
cloner and the up vector will be set to
positive why that didn't work let's try
positive z no let's just try them all
let's see what happens okay it looks
like none of them are working
hmm
why don't we do guys what do we do um
[Music]
hmm I wonder why is that not working
guys why is that not working it should
work
maybe go to transform okay there you go
yeah I just rotate it negative 90 so
they're standing up straight let's make
a lot more so we will go to the cloner
and the count will set that 200zoo - on
a 24 now we want some of these heads
they look very uniform right now don't
they so what we'll do is we'll use a
random modifier if we select the cloner
we got a mograph effector and let go on
random it's gonna randomly move these
things around okay if you go to
parameter let's we don't want to move
them up and down because they're stuck
to the ground right so let's set the Y
to zero and let's set the x and z
technically they're already randomly
spread around on the x and z so we
probably don't need the the position but
what we do want is rotation and probably
a little bit of scale so with rotation
checked you can move these around right
so we can go 360 on the the y axis you
know so they're just gonna spin this way
we can also go 20 degrees on the other
axes right so you can do like 10 and 10
maybe and that's gonna be like a really
cool way for for these things to be
spread around and actually they all are
standing
at the same height so I want to deal
with that too so maybe what we can do is
if we go to position and set I I want to
adjust the height on these but I also
want them to be connected to the ground
so what's the best way to do that maybe
it's through scale and we scale them on
the Y like this just a little bit but we
also want to scale it uniformly right so
I think that would be nice like
something like that and then absolutely
if you have absolute scale I think
[Music]
they'll go like what is house absolute
scale work versus without it checked oh
I think some to be honest I'm not really
sure right now I think they get scaled
more extremely but I could be wrong but
let's let's keep moving right that's
looking pretty good
let's work with the ground next so I'm
gonna take the plane let's up the
segments to like 200 by 200 and let's
hop out of camera view let's look at the
ground here and let's see I want to give
it some ridges and bumps right to make
it seem like it's actually uh you know
it has some there's a bit of difference
in the ground right and in the elevation
so I'm gonna select the plane I'm gonna
hold shift and hold down this little arc
this little bendy piece here and in this
area these are all modifiers that you
can use to modify your your what do you
call it your objects with and I'm gonna
let go on displacer
hopefully everyone's doing alright
everybody still with me thumbs up
everybody if you're still good
appreciate you guys so muskrats asking
what today's plan is basically we
created a super creepy head and I want
to put that head on a stake and I want
to put those stakes on a muddy ground in
a foggy area and I know that is really
jacked up but you know sometimes yeah I
just like creepy stuff so that's what
we're doing guys we're doing some creepy
stuff today
and we're going to get back to this
plane here if I go to shading and I
click shader and I click noise look at
that you see you see how it already is
doing some cool stuff we're gonna do
more of a macro adjustment across this
plane so we're gonna add some hills and
ridges and stuff and then we'll actually
use a texture for the detail right so
I'm gonna click the noise and let's go
to global scale 1000 right so it's more
of like a general thing let's even go mm
and let's take our contrast and just
crank it and you can see how it's gonna
get pretty extreme here like you can
even go to town on that but let's just
get some hills and ridges so that is
looking nice but let's keep pushing it
if you back out and go to object and set
the height to like 25 then you can
really start to see some ridges and
Hills going on here let's go to 30 and
if you go into the into the shader again
let's change change the global scale to
like 5000 that way we're getting some
more like hills and ridges and stuff
right there you guys can see that right
this is kind of like if you guys saw
1917 I'm going for like no-man's land
kind of vibe so now that we have that
let's some let's put a really
interesting texture on the ground here
so there's a website called rd -
textures comm and honestly these are the
highest quality textures I have ever
used
these things are absurd the detail on
these are through the roof they are the
best so you guys can see like this is
all not loading yeah look at this look
how realistic this stuff is he's using
the forest floor pack for that there's
rocks there's concrete there's a train
tracks scaffolding wood all this just
site takes a minute to load here but
yeah
it's just the best and they have some
really good mud stuff so that's what I'm
going to be using for this is their mud
and I'll make a new material I'll apply
the new material to the plane here and
it's a glossy material because we want
the mud to be wet and nasty and let's
let's load that in so let's see here
let's pull this up
okay so we have like tire mud right
that's awesome
we have sand mud like this and maybe we
can combine the two we can try that so
let's start with the tire mud okay and
let's like zoom in here so you guys can
really see the power the true power of
these arty textures here and you'll see
this thing transform it's gonna be
awesome this is my favorite part
so I'm gonna grab let's start with the
normal map and they come in 4k and 8k
texture sizes and I'm starting with the
normal map and you'll see right away
this stuff start to work I'm gonna give
it projection node change the projection
to box and that feels right to me let's
do the depth map next so that is our
displacement map okay that is where
these things shine all right so I'm
gonna go to this placement add
displacement we got our node I'll drag
that into the texture and make sure that
I use this texture projection on this as
well and you know what you know what is
this gonna work
I don't know this is gonna work because
I know there are some issues with
projection maps in c4 do you when you
set the when you change the projection
in here so I'm actually going to delete
that and reload the scene and I'm just
going to change the projection over here
so I must select the material over here
and change the projection here to flat
and that should give us the ability to
tile this thing more appropriately so
tiles instead of one let's set it to
like 10 oh my goodness let's try that
again
let's take the displacement texture down
to 10 tiles to reload in the scene I'm
just gonna try it this right why does it
look so jacked what if I just said it's
cubic
there we go that looks right we'll go
1.5 on the tiles perfect okay so now we
can keep building this thing out let's
take the displacement texture up to like
20 and I would go to 15
okay let's keep adding stuff so we'll do
a bump map next all right we'll drag
that in and this is all just detail on
detail on detail it's getting really
really nice and you can zoom way in here
and you can really see this stuff work
let's keep moving
[Music]
let's do next we will do hmm
let's do the color right pipe that into
the diffuse tab and we'll take the
displacement down again to ten
that's looking really gross and we want
to have it looked like it was rained on
so we're going to start piping in some
some specular maps some roughness maps
and these actually come with images for
like a wet look so we'll grab roughness
wet and just put that into the roughness
tab and we'll do the same with let's see
here the gloss map here gloss wet or
high oh there's a high gloss as well
let's do that
beautiful sweet so you can really see
the tiles from here on the ground but if
we go back to the camera view if we're
low enough yeah you can see it so let's
scale it up a little bit more well click
this will go to tiles we go let's go one
just set it back to default and let's go
even more let's set it to like 0.5 0.5
so it's getting larger awesome cool and
you see how like if let's here's a cool
trick if we add a plane and we scale it
way up and we can actually turn this
into water so let's do let's see we can
do this a couple different ways we can
do a glossy material drop that on the
new plane we just made we'll go to index
we'll set it to 1 so it's perfectly
reflecting the area and let's actually
grab like a different HDR imap here
something that is in like truly in the
middle of nowhere and more of an
overcast look see what racetrack sundown
looks like that could work but I think
in let's see commercial locations
there's some fog there's a foggy one
somewhere foggy Park with Sun yeah
that's what we're going for
yes yes this is the vibe right here this
is like Resident Evil 4 when you enter
the village for the first time yeah this
is this is getting cool
and we'll find we'll find our framing in
a second here
but let's um let's mess with the water
because it's not supposed to be just
chromed out let's actually make a
specular material so this is like glass
right and let's throw that on the plane
and let's check this is very important
if you go to common you check fake
shadows you'll be able to really like
see through this stuff and then let's do
uh let's see here
let's give it a bit of texture so if we
add absorption an absorption medium to
it you'll be able to kind of see through
like the water will be a little bit
murky alright and we can do let's see
let's see absorption and if you add a
RGB spectrum to that you can probably
change it to like a brownish look that's
pretty cool then we'll bring the plane
down a little bit more maybe
[Music]
that's feeling pretty cool um let's do
let's combine this mud with a different
material as well and I hope you guys are
doing alright
sweet sweet thanks for falling along
yeah join that discord channel so you
guys can post your work as well
we all give each other some helpful
advice on our work alright so I'm gonna
copy over this material go into it and
let's let's actually apply it right
because we're gonna change some of these
attributes and we're gonna make a whole
new material and it's gonna be more of
like the kind of like a you know show
I'll just show you guys it'll be more
like this right where there's sticks and
stuff on the ground too
and I'm just gonna drag and drop to
replace these images so there's the bump
map and the color
then we have our depth map as well and
we have muddy high-gloss we have an our
normal map and our roughness map and I'm
just gonna scale this stuff down
obviously it's uh it looks too big right
now awesome and then let's just take the
scaling of this down to like 0.25 whoa
okay the other way let's go to 2
and let's keep going let's go like three
and let's take the displacement Oh said
our mid-level 20.5 I've always said that
mid-level 20.5 let's think that it's
placement and crank the height up
I still think it's too big
oh it's set to UV mapping we need to set
it to a cubic and then go back to the
0.5 deal yeah that feels that feels
better
awesome so I want to combine these two
materials together okay so the best way
to do that is with an octane mixed
material so we'll go to materials and we
will use an octane mixed material and
that's the coolest thing about octane is
you can mix as many materials together
as possible for infinite combinations
and let's drop this mud material but
let's let's try that again with your
mixed material selected let's drag and
drop the octane material into slot one
and then the second mature we made let's
drag that into slot two I'm just going
to rename the stuff to mud and this is
like sand sand I'm just gonna call sand
for now
we'll go into the mixed material node
editor and let's let's just make sense
of all this stuff here I'm gonna right
click these and hit auto arrange
selected I'll select the hierarchy where
is that where the boom select hierarchy
and so you can move this as a whole I'll
do the same here auto arrange select
hierarchy move it over to the side so we
have these two nodes here this is our
material one this is our material two
and it's being piped into this mix
material right here and it's being
distributed with this float texture so
it's half in half right and oh let's not
forget to apply our material to our
plane reload our scene and why oh it's
messing with the oh okay yeah we three
do this let's set the projection of
cubic tiles to 0.4 0.4 reload the scene
again
okay so it's blending them 5050 but we
don't want that so let's delete that and
let's make a noise map and we're going
to basically basically with a noise map
anything that's black is material 1
anything that's white is material 2 so
with that in mind let's select this and
let's just crank our contrast up to 100
and then there you go you can see right
there that the materials were
distributed evenly right but that
doesn't look good either
so let's actually see if we can't mess
with this a little bit let's go to
octaves let's go 10 octaves on that and
Omega will set that to point 8 so we're
getting a lot more detail in the way
it's being broken up and if I right
click the noise hits solo node oh it's
still difficult to see so don't worry
about that
let's go to 0.9 on the Omega and that's
really breaking it up nicely and we'll
take the contrast and start walking it
back down
okay contrast 25 and if you take the
noise and you add a projection map to it
and set it to box and then we do the we
add a trend you'd be transformed to it
we can start to kind of skill this noise
up so you have a bit it's it's just the
larger right so you have large chunks of
mud larger chunks of dirt I'm gonna go
to 15 even on this thing and you can set
the noise type you can change the noise
type which is cool turbulence a circular
look like what about chips
I think purlins was getting us a nice
look there
so let's take the sand texture and just
mess with the color of it a little bit
I'd like to make it a little darker to
match that mud a bit more so in the
diffuse tab here I'm just gonna scroll
down and add a color correction node to
it and it looks like the mm-hmm we want
to darken it a bit so maybe we'll just
take the brightness down to like 0.7
that kind of gets us there 0.6 feels
pretty nice yeah that's that's pretty
awesome it's hot back into our camera
and see what that looks like
yeah it's looking pretty cool pretty
creepy very nice very very nice now the
only thing I don't like is that the
water here is like the edge is so sharp
so there might be a way to like how
would I do that
Roth wick Roth wicks is asking what are
we doing today what are your plans for
this render so I just put out a video on
corridor is a scary video where a flying
ghostly head attacks Sam and Nico
they're ghost hunters and we just kind
of went through how to make this creepy
floating head I was like you know what
let's throw it on the stick and let's
put it in no man's land and add some fog
and make a cool picture so that's what
we're doing today Connor says you could
use noise as a factor for the bump of
the water for more detail yeah totally
totally hey that's a good point
so let's um let's go back to the water
here and I'm gonna use the go into the
specular let's go to the bump and let's
just add noise
and let's see go to our node editor and
for noise let's see I'll do it this way
I'll add noise from here bump add
projection set it the Box UV transform
and we'll scale it up a little bit
alright so we have a little bit of
detail on the water there some ripples
which is looking really nice but I still
have that edge that hard edge and
technically there's a way to do this
where it's like adding making concrete
wet and stuff and making it look wet but
it'd be difficult in this situation
what's the best way to do this mmm it's
getting tricky because we're dealing
with different scaling across different
textures let's come back to that detail
because we may not even notice depending
on a camera angle so we don't want to
waste time here so let's um as a last
little deal here let's uh let's add some
fog so octane fog is great it's called
octane fog volume let's spawn one of
those let's go to a yeah it's basically
sitting right there and it's really
dense right out the gates it's very very
dense so what we're gonna do and it's
also very intense on your system I'm
gonna select the volume I'm gonna hide
it from our renderer for now okay that's
that that's that bottom circle and in
our viewport let's see let's go to main
generate and the voxel size let's set
that to 100 if you go to a lower number
than 5 like 3 or 2 or god forbid 1 you
will you will blow up your system so
just be very careful with the fog here
because if we're going over a large area
it can get really tricky
really quick let's grow the scale of
this thing let's make it larger and
let's push it forward okay just bring it
into the area that we're dealing with
okay so it's like a low-lying fog right
now which is pretty sweet actually hop
back in here and
let's turn it on in the renderer and
it's not looking good it looks like but
so how do you fix that you go to medium
alright
click this little image here the volume
medium and you have scattering and you
have absorption okay
but first let's take the density and
just set it to one let's set it
let's try setting it to 0.1 and it we
want it to be pretty subtle
let's try point 0.35 let's try that
let's move it up
it's actually pretty sweet let's take
the absorption and changed the color to
a brighter color and we'll take the
scattering and make it a little darker
and you should set your fog to path
tracing or not you don't set your fog to
path tracing you set your scene to path
tracing and let's see let's mess with
the density here let's try 0.25 and
let's take the scattering phase and
crank that up and I want to be able to
just have it be like a wall of fog in
the background so maybe what I'll do
instead of using this this HDRI image
I'm gonna just grab a color like this
right but just take it down in the
background so we're kind of getting this
eerie this eerie fog here let's make it
brighter let's make the fog brighter
something like this very Silent Hill
I'm taking the background down and then
let's add let's add a Sun that looks
really cool I'm gonna hide the volume
from our picture viewer so we can see
what we're doing make sure you save your
scene
and let's bring our Sun and point it
let's see where where it's going on here
so I'm directing our Sun right at us
here hopefully it's going oh I'm
changing the volume I'm sorry guys let's
try that again
let's bring the Sun around here
and take the turbidity to like 10 and
let's set our fog volume a scattering
phase let's see let's move that down a
little bit let's take the density back
to 1
maybe 0.75 or so all right and let's
move the fog up and then scale it up
like this ooh now this is getting this
is again spooky all right let's see
let's see let's take the sky color of
our Sun here and that's like mix the sky
texture with the background we made so
that's going to use the color the HDRI
as our sky but we still have our Sun
piercing through take the density let's
go to 0.5 and I'm kind of feeling the
vibes here this is getting creepy
yeah this is nice
all right let's try a little bit of
color correction on this just gonna set
the camera up
and let's grab the camera here and let's
go to camera imager and turn that on and
this is this is awesome so basically you
can add in different let's our color
looks and oh man that already it's so
creepy I love it
we'll set the gamut at 2.2 that is so
creepy I love it so much
let's let's add a vignette for now we
can we can kind of take that off or add
it later I like to add it later but for
now I'm kind of feeling that we can make
this a black-and-white image which I
think would make it a little spooky er
that's cool but I don't know I always go
back and forth between black and white
in color because I think that looks
really nice too you can take the
exposure to like 1.5 so now you have to
ask yourself if you were photographer
and you were here how would you frame
this up you know I really like center
frame stuff this is this is getting
spooky guys that's so creepy in the
water like that
Jakub wish you would have seen this
before rendering your duck video well
dude I'm glad you've joined and I'm glad
we're learning a thing or two so next
time you make duck video number two
you'll be a little bit better off yeah
all right so we're nearing the end here
we're getting close to this final image
is everyone doing all right everyone's
hanging in we've had a healthy stream
you know we've had like about 65 people
in this thing the whole time so I'm glad
you guys are in I'm glad you guys are
doing this ah all right dang Douglass
going on your first plane ride tomorrow
good luck man listen to some ambient
music and chill out because it helps it
helps a lot all right
I'm a mess with the water a little bit
see if we can't see if we can't improve
the quality of this thing
maybe we'll bring it down
tiny little puddles maybe there's just
little tiny puddles I don't know it was
nice the way it was before it is so
creepy so yeah you could start getting
tricky with your the placement of these
sticks here maybe you'll take the camera
and go really wide with this this is
like 15 or something
and maybe this is better from another
angle like over here or something
just gonna have to move around and see
what works best you know
I'm finding I'm finding the frame here
that looks the coolest ad this is pretty
nicer here
let's try a 35 see if that gives us a
cooler look
this is pretty cool I like this
that's creepy super creepy and you can
always adjust the the seed of the way
things are spread around here so you can
just kind of cycle through this that's
not bad
ooh that's actually not bad right there
that's cool yes yes heck yeah
this is looking nice so we're very close
we just got to drop the heads in I might
want to like switch out some of the
sticks so that there's a bit more
[Music]
jaggedness to them perhaps and I really
want the the ground to feel a bit more
wet and you're saying oh joel is saying
it's maybe lacking something to give me
a sense of scale and I think that's a
good that's a very good note it's like
what can you grab on to - no oh this is
that size or this is that size and well
we have heads so that's gonna help but I
think like a fence or something like a
nasty-looking fence through here or
maybe some like trash or garbage or
something or uh you know we can search
through the mega scans library and see
if there's anything cool that we can add
to the scene here if we go to 3d assets
and we can just like drop some like
debris yeah here's debris so you know
like there's trash I feel like there
wouldn't be trash out here maybe there'd
be rocks stones or something I think
there definitely be some sticks and
stuff so maybe we can throw some sticks
in there and sky
those around let's see let's see
we could put some trees in here actually
see now branches like this right this is
I feel like the heads would be on
something like this to really go to town
yeah like this kind of stuff so we could
switch that out like tree branches and
stuff we could also put some tree stumps
in the background as well which I think
would be really nice really really cool
umm but you could also do like you could
probably use like Forester to get some
creepy trees back here too so what would
that look like I'm just gonna use force
there plug in make a tree real quick
and let's go to our tree library and
find the creepiest looking tree we can
find like a cork tree like this could be
pretty interesting and not give it any
leaves or anything you know ooh yeah
like this this is cool
branch level straighten tops there's all
these look these all these like settings
here I'm just gonna find the right the
right tree that's not bad
that's not bad
yeah I can just go through here oh I
feel like that's the one the weeping
willow yes I feel like this is the one
that's creepy that's a creepy tree tree
parameters let's see let's go back to
our let's just put that tree way back
there let's go back into our door scene
and let's bring this tree up yeah that's
that's that's creepy you can have a few
of those so I can bring the size of the
tree down to like 0.5 dude hang our
corpse to the tree oh man that'd be the
freakin one man would be the move oh
that's awesome
yeah I love that that is creepy as all
and until this camera up something like
that and then if we wanted to change the
sticks out let's see if I can't open up
I might have some pre saved ones here
because they're too straight I don't
like the straightness of the sticks I
think we can go for more jagged look
branches debris and twigs whoa oops
let's try that again
okay yeah so I have a lot of sticks here
from mega scans so we can find a few
that work for us
just want to find something that's nice
and jagged and sturdy and you know
something that would be doable like I
think this one's pretty good right here
let's see what else I have tree branch
that's a little too much hmm
these ones might also be a bit much I
think I'm at the going and just kind of
like choose one that works for what
we're doing yeah these are all too short
but I'm pretty sure I have ooh okay I
have a dead tree that's pretty creepy
hmm decisions guys decisions this is
where the detail comes in and I take
forever to do something but heck I mean
we're here we're doing it all right
let's just go back to mega scans and see
if we can't find a nice twig or stick
that works for us
tree branch yeah this one's good see if
I get like a pack of tree branches these
are nice
I think we'll go with these two right
here let's download these guys and the
other one boom download that okay so
that's going what else do we need for
our scene here suggestions are welcome
y'all suggestions are very welcome so
hmm
having some stuff scattered on the
ground would be cool the tree definitely
helps bring it together we're gonna
change out the branches let's see if we
can't make this ground a bit more wet
right in here so we'll go to the mix
material and let's take off the
roughness and the specular oh got Dan
second crash of the day but we're coming
back quick we're gonna make the ground a
bit more wet and reflective who a crow
yes a crow crows that is a great
suggestion maybe a light source like
something burning or a dropped
flashlight okay
I like the crow idea sitting on the on
the feature head okay
some crows on the willow could be creepy
agreed playing Pokemon while watching
the stream heck yeah freakin love
Pokemon one of my favorite games ever um
a human did I read that human in a cage
you guys are freaking twisted they're a
human cage like in a willow the dead
tree is perfect for dangling a skeleton
okay yeah for sure for sure um I like
the crows
I think the crows a great idea um I
think that one of the things that I'm
struggling with in this image is which
is the hero head fair enough fair enough
we'll figure out if we want a hero head
or if we just want more of like a
general vibe where the head isn't just
BAM right in the front
I do like subtlety but we'll see well
mess with that maybe some cattails or
weeds or something okay Oh weeds yeah we
could do some weeds we can do a little
bit at a doll hanging from the tree
hanging rope or some sort of effigy like
let's see okay these are all great great
suggestions
so let's gather our assets turbosquid
dot-com we're going in we're going in
for a crow I think that's a great idea
we're gonna go to four oh there's zero
free crows guys what about a dollar is
there are there dollar crows dollar menu
crows hmm
this one's eight bucks that's not bad
let's try a free 3d comm crow ha this
crow is free dude why does the freaking
JPEG have to be so low quality oh it
just looks horrible um let's try it
we're here right let's do it let's try
this okay 3d models crow all right it's
gonna be a virus or something ridiculous
here's the thing it's low poly but
that's okay because it's gonna be in the
background I'm gonna put it like
scattered on the tree or something I'll
have to figure out how to do that in a
second but uh okay
let's drag in this crow obj and see what
we got okay oh my goodness what's
happening what is even happening I can't
see it so is it tiny or large I can't
tell well it's tiny okay so we need to
scale this thing up
there's our guy
this will totally work for us it's very
low poly but it's going to work we're
just gonna honestly slap a black diffuse
material on this crow and call it a day
it's gonna be as black as night does it
even have it doesn't even have a it
doesn't even have a texture it didn't
even come with a texture but it doesn't
matter it doesn't even matter guys
alright so I'm gonna copy this thing
paste it into our scene here don't get
out of camera view and let's move this
thing up to the tree where we're at
where are you where are you crow so if I
wanted to scatter this thing around the
tree yeah I could just start like
placing it manually but that's that is
no fun can you even see him is it up
there this is so ridiculous
let me let me try something crazy here
let me try scattering like the same way
we scattered these heads let me try
scattering these crows so I want this
crow I'm gonna scatter this crow with an
octane scatter I want to distribute it
across the surface of this willow tree
and I want there to be 20 of them and is
it even working
it's thinking okay not why is it working
it's not working
hmm maybe I have to make the tree
editable I'm gonna duplicate the tree
hit see oh my goodness it's editable
let's take off the leaves we're left
with the branches there's a lot of
branches I just want the main branch the
main chunk here so I'm going to zoom in
great okay
Wow wow that's a lot
ha Melanie thank you that's awesome
that is a super chat I just enabled it
last week great idea on the crow but
thank you so much that's very very kind
of you thank you for doing that
I didn't want to I didn't want to say
that I had the super chat thing because
it's kind of awkward but yeah it's there
that's a super chat and Melanie just did
it for 5 euros so thank you thank you
thank you so much Melanie that is
amazing God you guys are awesome yes
this is awesome
sweet okay so we're trying to figure out
how to scatter Melanie's crow across
this tree
I might just manually place these things
because this is gonna take a minute like
for me to figure out how to do this it's
just gonna take a minute so I'm gonna no
let's just delete the tree let's turn
this thing back on let's get these crows
out and let's just start manually
placing these things
let's see Adrian says adding another
light source could be cool the fog is
flattening the image quite a bit even
just some red eyes on the crow put the
curl on one of the heads closer to
camera yeah agreed agreed
feed him the hanging eye that's
hilarious
the human cage referring to the movie
willow oh not the willow tree what's
trouble to work branches looking weak oh
you guys things sketchfab try sketchfab
I will definitely do that next time the
shadow someone walking by the tree could
be interesting some gravestones could
also be interesting
Dylan trying to figure out what the
stream about is about dude so the stream
is about well I'm using cinema 4d trying
to teach you guys cinema 4d and how to
create a cool image every week every
Saturday and make something awesome and
every every Saturday we do something
different right so I might focus on
texturing I'm focused on modeling I
might you know focus on taking an image
and bringing it from start to finish but
really it's a chance for you guys
and all of us to get together every
Saturday and work on our passion so if
that's drawing for you like Melanie I
knows she loves drawing so she's gonna
do that right a lot of you are using
blender some of you are using c40 and
following along with what I'm doing here
but the point is to learn the points to
grow the point is to continue working on
our passion and honestly this is stuff I
love doing so I'm gonna be doing this
regardless and having a good time but
I'm just moving this crow manually now
this is definitely the chump way of
doing things but it will probably get us
to where we need to be a skill that guy
down let's go up let's get one on this
branch here alright and you just want to
make sure the rotation is all different
but you do want to have a silhouette you
want to get your silhouettes down wait a
second why is the crow not there
oh it's cuz it's in the scatter still
why is it yeah okay okay so still going
with the crows moving these guys around
holding control to click-and-drag oh god
man navigation here
let's move this guy back right in there
and really I'm just kind of don't have
to be too precise because we're just
going for silhouettes so if we go back
into our camera view and we just do a
little render region here on the tree
you should be able to see some crows up
in there and sure enough they are up in
that tree but let's get them on these
bottom branches too a little bit
all right let's go one here
trying to get this guy down on to this
branch and again this is a pretty chumpy
way of doing this but you know I could
select the exact polygons I want to put
the birds onto and then just kind of
scatter them across those I could just
do a top-down selection of polygon
points and and do it that way as well
but we're almost there you know I just
the reason I'm doing it this way is
because the amount of time it would take
to do it any other way
would probably just be as long as what
I'm doing right here and also we do get
to kind of art direct it you know
well not kinda we 100% get to art direct
it because we're choosing exactly where
these crows go and we're moving them
around whereas the scatter thing you
know you you can kind of do that if
you're choosing the right points and
stuff but we're almost done here
I'm such a huge fan of Resident Evil for
you guys remember that game when you
like go to the village for the first
time and they're all there's the crows
everywhere and stuff you shoot a crow
you get a grenade total total classic
all right go let's go back to our camera
view and yeah there's there's crows up
in that tree certainly that's awesome
okay um Dylan says in the future you
should do something like getting viewers
project files and seeing what you would
do to change it help them with a
question would be a fun interactive way
to do things I agree I want to be able
to have this be more of an interactive
thing obviously like I'm reading your
guys's comments and we're talking about
stuff as we're going but yeah I want to
figure out like fun little games that we
can do together
or fun little render challenges that we
can to do together I think it would be
awesome so I'm definitely definitely
keeping that in mind and I would love to
at some point like maybe start a patreon
or something for this where I can
provide project files to you guys and do
one-on-one chats and we can do
one-on-one like classes or maybe even
like ten people we can get in get a
class going together I think that could
be interesting if you guys are down for
that yeah I just want to be able to
provide as much value and content to you
guys as possible and right now it's just
you know Saturday for a couple hours so
I would need a bit more time to put into
it you know a bit of I need to think
about it a little bit more and figure
out what's the best way to go about that
what's the best way to build this out
and you guys are totally helping me here
by being very vocal here in the chat and
helping me brainstorm so I appreciate
that maybe Center the willow just a
little bit you said so uh maybe
off-center the willow Oh so here's the
thing about the the willows I love
symmetrical images so I just
put that willow center frame you know
what I mean but thank you for the
suggestion I appreciate it Jacob what
did I miss
we're making a creepy scene we modeled
ahead we're gonna put heads on these
steaks
Melanie suggested we put a crow up in
those trees so we put a crow up in those
trees we did some textures we you know
made the ground all muddy and gross
about to make it wet um Pablo yeah
resident for was the best super
nostalgic ooh okay 15 degree Dutch tilt
I could I'll see you on that I will see
you on that
the fog volume is at an actual fog
volume it's not a Z depth pass but that
would be a quick way to do it um could
you somehow allow us to make a natural
looking glow in our scenes you read that
one more time could you somehow show us
how to make it okay okay natural glow so
if you're using cinema 4d and you're
using octane there's actually a post
process pass if you click the camera tag
here I've got a post-processing you
click that and you can start tweaking
these numbers here to get a nice glow in
the scene so you can crank that you can
crank really crank those numbers to get
a nice glow going which is pretty nice
that's not bad
we can mess with that a little bit
certainly certainly
um yeah some challenges will be fun I
agree
a Slenderman behind all of this could be
interesting Brett dude I'm surprised
you're still here son it's been almost
three hours son let's get that breast
gate rotate going that's my favorite
let's see just a little bit right just
just enough to be like something doesn't
feel right here ooh
well yeah that's creepy
that's creepy how far do you wanna take
this though you trying to go all the way
son how far you trying to take this son
I'll take you to the max I think just
the subtle little twist to it is super
creepy yeah that's awesome
let's see Douglas I was not imagining
watching this at midnight on a Saturday
but this is very pleasant I am very
thankful and I appreciate it
I hope it's chill for you dude
the okay uh magnificent been asked
what's the best octane alternative I'd
love it but a little pricey for me right
now dude honestly blender
I think it's free for blender so check
out blender gather up three models put
them in a Google Drive and give yourself
in viewers like an hour or two to make
and render something cool yeah like the
people challenge we did that'd be
awesome that's a good idea that's a
really good idea we'll do like render
challenges together that's a super good
idea thing might we might have to do
that next week mmm a little warm it's
like a fire somewhere if I thought about
a little fire
Oh what about lanterns like what about
some lanterns or something we could do
that something you could only see in the
reflection of the water oh man that's a
good idea that's a good idea that's
going to be super creepy
that could be super creepy yeah like
some tall like person standing here and
then select for example if we had a
let's see what's the best way to do this
if we had a figure standing right here
on the little beach here right and you
just give them a really dark texture and
then you could add an octane object tag
go to visibility turn off camera
visibility and see how you can still see
their legs down here like that could be
super cool so I might mess with that a
little bit as well certainly certainly
could be very interesting I like that
idea
um police lights from behind the camera
oh dang that's good too man you guys yes
look at that happy Saturday from
Soundwave man y'all you all heck yeah
Soundwave with the super chat that's my
third one of all time I got my second
one from Melanie you guys are freaking
awesome thank you so much God dang this
is awesome
Soundwave I appreciate you very very
much thank you for joining the stream
thank you for the super chat really
really appreciate it very much
[Music]
wow you guys are great what else could
we do a person with a machete add
something like a person just to see part
of him like an eye or a silhouette maybe
someone behind the tree or something hmm
what if the reflection of the sticks
were body shaped instead oh man that
would be next level I feel like okay I
feel like you'd have to change the I
would I would have to change the like
the setup of the picture I'd have to
change the point of the picture so the
tree getting the tree and the sticks and
everything it'd be pause okay look it'd
be possible if we did this if instead of
a horizontal view we went vertical
all right and we zoomed in or rather we
punched in
grapes don't under the tree yeah
certainly certainly how about some kind
of Slenderman looking thing okay how
about some torn clothes fabric hanging
from the tree could be good yeah it
could be good III I think the focus on
the crows is nice I want to add more
crows probably more to the outside of
this thing you guys like vertical better
super Dutch angle with the Freak who's
only visible and the reflection would be
great so you see what I mean though you
have to change the it's more of a
vertical frame so you see more of the
water now we get the tree and the the
reflection down below and if we went
into the reflection here and we went to
the medium and we changed let's see the
absorption if we just went white with
the absorption would that make the water
brighter hmmm difficult to tell
difficult to tell the roughness put the
roughness up no that was not going to do
it
now we could fake it and just add an
area light whoa that's creepy who
suspend crows in the air like having
them flying by kind of thing or just
like freaking like death stranding crows
floating you know Freddie I made a
render with the exact same vibe as well
today so that's awesome hope you having
a good time yes I'm having a great time
and that's cool that you did a render
very similar we're on the same
wavelength here the tree on fire is seen
in the reflection dang that be sweet
I'll be freakin creepy
that's not bad not bad at all something
floating in the water beer bottle or
something yeah that's a good idea or a
tire or trout like leaves we could do
like leaves scattered across the water
ooh
crows flying away like something just
happened okay that's not bad but I think
that's gonna be easiest in Photoshop
after the fact yeah I think they'll be
easiest in Photoshop after the fact okay
I hear all your suggestions
they are amazing let's continue let's um
let's change out the sticks right we
were gonna do that in a minute ago so
let's let's take care of that okay
so let's load these guys in
stick number one
we just need the color we need the
roughness and we need the normal map so
I'm gonna drag those into the scene here
and I don't even need to render it
because I know that this stuff is gonna
work no problem and my computer is
catching up with me here
all right so that's number one and let's
go branch number two what the heck
Freddie with the frickin super Chad what
dude I don't know what and okay is but
good goodness Wow Wow dude thank you so
much that is awesome man dang I don't
know what to say
um Freddie thank you besides yeah thank
you so much it's very very very kind of
you to do that man that that is freaking
so cool
Wow I really hope yeah I hope you guys
are getting something out of this hope
because you're learning from this this
is really fun for me and it's really
really really cool to see that you guys
are down for this experience so Wow
Freddie dude you were the man Thank You
Man dude that is awesome
there's awesome dude just for that just
for that man let's do a little bit of
something here
let's do let's do a little bit of this
let's hop in here
boom thanks Freddie
oh it's with the why I means to spill in
for other other Freddie other Freddie's
name Thank You Freddie dude let's get
you a better font than a default font
man let's get you some freaking like
what's this one mmm friggin Splinter
Cell font and we'll get that uh we'll
get that like chromed out chromed out
look and then we'll go with like a
little pro studios metal boom appreciate
it man appreciate it
that's crazy too kind too kind
all right um I think we have where was I
what happened we have a branch and we're
gonna drop it into this scene and let's
see let's see
come on computer I know you can do it
awesome
yeah you guys Rock thank you so much for
doing this whoo a hand sticking out of
the water could be could be sweet
Oh Amir what's up Amir Amir is a very
good friend from Georgia and Brett
Brett's from Georgia as well so good to
see you Amir Amir is freaking awesome
he's a good photographer a good artist
he's actually got a lot of his prints on
sale as well at his store and I'm sorry
I misused he's not a photographer he's
an he's an artist so he draws a lot of
really cool stuff very fancy looking
stuff it's very very talented CG studio
welcome welcome welcome
man you guys are dark dead body floating
on the water snap okay let's let's get
focused here we have our tree branch
let's get the other branch going
[Music]
tree branch number three
we'll do the same deal make a new
texture roughness normal color drop
those in and you know apologies for I
have to load these assets in and this is
not fun to watch but at least you guys
get an idea of how to do this in c4d and
I just hope that you guys are getting
something from this so we just did that
we just loaded our texture onto this
branch we're gonna copy this branch and
paste it into our scene as well so we
have both assets there cool cool and
then let's set this up so that let's
group our crows just clean up a little
bit we have our cloner and it's on our
steak so we turn the cloner off and we
see our steak is here so let's take the
tree branches and match that so we'll
scale this thing or move it up and let's
rotate it so it's standing up tall like
this
and let's move the access point or the
gizmo down to the bottom of this thing
but first let's just change it so it's
right side up and we'll get that point
Center down to the bottom okay why did
thatin I did not work there we go
so we got that one we'll scale it down
and we'll get the little head right on
there and well delete maybe we'll keep
that one there as well so we'll have
like a different variety of heads and
sticks and stuff and I think that's
really that's really gonna add to to the
scene here and then we'll do our last
branch we'll rotate that guy have 90
degrees move it up and we'll also get
the axis down to the bottom of this guy
oh okay so if you notice we rotated it
the y-axis is looking to the right we
want to check this little enable access
tool and that way you're gonna move the
axis around right so you just want to
zero out the rotation so it's proper and
then you can execute that move and it'll
work scale it down as well okay and dude
Ahmed with the freaking super jet Sun
Sun dang
heck yeah you guys Rock so much Thank
You Ahmed dude let's get the super chat
ball rolling dude heck yeah appreciate
you dude
thank you sir Thank You Ahmed Rock On
Dude
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you so much you guys are freaking
awesome
yeah the super chat is freaking great
and just just so you guys know I do have
a website so if you do want to donate a
little bit and get something back
this is a good way to do so as well
they're a little bit pricier right
they're 40 bucks a shot and it does
scale up if you want a larger size but
you guys do get something in return
obviously not like you're not getting
something here right now because we're
learning stuff and teaching stuff and
doing stuff together my god Forked CD
Studio son y'all y'all y'all made me do
a spin move thank you so much your
contributions are much appreciated very
much appreciated I can get a couple more
computers now because of you guys so I
appreciate it and and sarasu is
collaborate with Fran on the next stream
I think that's a good idea I think
that's a very good idea God dang yellow
freaking awesome much appreciated
Chad Ashley oh my god freaking check
chad Ashley but guys do you guys know
who Chad Ashley is forget him look chad
ashley is the man he is the texture
master look at this guy look at this guy
right here boom Chad Ashley coming at
you
BAM Chad Ashley works at Grayskull
gorilla and I learned a lot of what I am
doing right now from Chad he is one of
the texture masters and he's got look he
did this everyday collection material
collection right here and I use it a lot
it's fantastic super high-res stuff he's
just making it from scratch like a
friggin boss
so Chad Ashley it is an honor and a
privilege to have you in the stream I
appreciate it very very much
all right so let's keep moving here
we're putting these heads on sticks here
so let's do a little copy/paste action
let's move this guy up a little bit get
out of the axis mode hitting s to snap
the viewport to the object I have
selected and now we have our three
scatter head stick thingies here so I'm
just gonna give these little random
rotation all right let's see so now I
can take those three sticks with the
heads on them and put it in the cloner
so let's just make sure everything's
organized we have our tree branches
let's put that under steak and we want
to split those up a little bit so it's
not we're not you know cloning these 3d
Lee's we want to clone them individually
so let's just get smart with this here
we want this tree branch and that head
together so we'll group those and then
we want this head and that little piece
together so we'll group those and now
you see how we have the three different
options right you put those in a cloner
you turn the cloner back on hop back in
your camera mode and would you look at
that we're getting some variety but if
you notice it looks like things are
duplicated so I think what we're gonna
do is just need to tweak our random
modifier just a bit so if we go to the
effect I'm sorry if we go to parameter
okay let's uncheck scale we'll just
leave scale as is we're gonna want to
mess I think with the rotation a bit
more so
the thing that's really giving it away
from me is like these two right in the
foreground are very similar so we could
just kind of like we could add more
options we could add more stakes and
more variety um now why are my sticks
floating let's sum let's zoom in here
and get out of camera view and let's uh
let's take a look at this here and this
stick is certainly floating and that one
is very deep underground and and I think
the reason that's happening to be honest
is because we're scattering these sticks
over this plane right here and I don't
think it's taking the DES former into
account so we could let's see
CG studio thank you for the super chat I
see you man very generous very very kind
much appreciated
coming back at it freaking Christian
with another super chat thank you sir
much appreciated
thanks for the kombucha dude keeping me
healthy heck yeah thank you thank you so
yeah I think the I think the plane is
not or the scatter is not accounting the
deformer so how do we do this here how
do we do this if there's any suggestions
I'm all ears let's see
add some vines the moss all right it's
been fun see you saturday Douglas
Douglas the shrimp appreciate you
brother see on the next one substance
painter yes I would love some substance
painter freaking love substance painter
and Chad is actually super good at
substance painter or substance designer
rather I actually don't know if he's
messed with painter but yeah substance
is awesome super super cool program
where you basically make textures with
black and white noise maps and CG studio
dude with the friggin super chat again
dude appreciate you man
appreciate you thank you thank you
that's awesome okay Joel says put the
plane in a connect and maybe clone from
that okay yeah that's a good idea so
let's do that with the plane selected
I've hold alt and come down into this
little drop-down and choose connect and
then reference that in the cloner so
instead of the plane will do the connect
and it's thinking
I think it's thinking um no that didn't
work
maybe is there like I don't really know
mmm I could obviously just make it
editable I can make the plane editable
which I'll probably just do because I'm
happy with the way the plane is
deforming so just in case I'll control
drag to duplicate that and I will hit C
or press this little button up here or
this button up here alright if I'd undo
that hit C or make editable and that
should do I have to okay maybe I need to
select both right click connect objects
+ delete that'll do it
so now in our cloner will reference that
and god thanks he g studio with a freak
another super chat dude holy crap thank
you appreciate you man thank you so much
that's awesome yeah we get that super
chat ball rollin that's great
is it supposed to be skulls that can be
skulls we made some creepy faces that we
can add on
it but let's just make sure this clone
is working right now why is this cloner
still not working I don't understand I
don't understand
I'm cloning these objects across plane
three and they're like undergrad let me
turn off the random modifier so it's why
are some underground and some are above
ground I feel like the random modifier
it's not is it like not does it think
the y-axis is actually something else
what if I zeroed out this position I'm
so confused now
what is going on is it transform oh I
think it looks like they're rotating
from different axes okay that'd be the
brute force way of doing it you could
try increasing the height of all the
sticks a lot and then move them up but I
I know this can work I know this can
work let me just check what I'm cloning
so let's turn off the cloner
let's hit s - snap - I think this is why
you see how they're kind of like they're
not sitting proportional and there
that's why look it's because the axis
for this is right there and when it's
rotating stuff its rotating it from
different points so what we need to do
is hit L or enable our axis tool and
just move this down to the bottom you
could also use the axis Center tool here
and just execute that point Center
include children use all objects and
let's add you point center that should
work yeah that feels right to me and
let's just do that for all of these here
so this is going to need to let's do the
same so that's at the bottom but since
it's like a wonky shape will manually
scoot this access point over hit s to
try and snap said that boom so that's in
the center and then finally we'll do the
last one which that one actually is
floating you can see it I think this is
gonna fix our issue
it's just our access points here boom
okay so that should work
CG studio with freaking super chats
again change the pivot of the object yes
yes absolutely I see you dude so now I
feel like now this is gonna work I'm
gonna zero out the position of all of
these right now just to triple just to
be triple clear that's gonna work now
let's turn it back on go back into this
view here and now I believe it is
working yes
Ahmed thank you I really appreciate you
brother thank you for the super chat
thank you for your donation and thank
you for coming to the chat and they're
coming to our stream here and learning a
thing or two and joining us and making
something awesome I'll see you on the
next one dude
okay so there's still a lot of copy
paste here in these sticks so we'll deal
with that a little later you know it's
just a lot of grunt work that it's not
too exciting so um let's go to our
random modifier and let's turn the
position back on I liked that the
rotation yeah it's nice I'm going to get
rid of the Dutch for now just so I don't
lose my mind and the tree the tree we
can make a little darker let's um let's
actually spread some like dead grass
around the the ground here so I'm gonna
do that by loading in some mega scans
assets here once again with the mega
scans let's see
if you guys don't know about these guys
my goodness they're the best 3d assets
they should have plants or something
tree it would have been our trees 3d
assets they might just have a whole one
for 3d plants they do so all this stuff
like grass you can get some dead grass
so everything's pretty dead in our scene
so we'll do that let's get some dead
grass going um
let's bring that in
were you at dead grass I know you're
around here somewhere
mega scans 3d assets plants gonna be
grassy clumps dry grass dry plant sure
let's try dry grass what are you looking
like dragula dry grass what are you
looking like these days Oh hgri browser
hello what's going on here we go this
will work and once again if c40 is going
a little slow on you just look at that
bottom left and see what it's doing it's
generating materials so just give it a
second you don't know you don't want to
break anything remember to save row
roben I think that's a pronounced name
says remember to save and I agree with
you you should always save
dude we've been going for three hours
right now my goodness we're gonna wrap
this thing up pretty quick but I could
do this all day this is very fun for me
but I do need to eat at some point so
let's uh let's finish this thing up her
kids CG Studios 400 I don't even know
what that is whoa that's like yen or
something dude
regardless much appreciated dude that is
awesome
he asks CG studio asks mouse or graphics
tablet which one do you like the most so
right now I am using a mouse it's
actually a rat
this thing is ridiculous I've had this
for so long for so so so long it's a
gaming you so many times I've clicked
look at that just wearing away at this
thing it looks like a jet-engine thing
you can actually move these pieces
around and comes with different parts
you shape it to your hand there's like a
aim-assist button right here it slows
down the sensitivity you can throw
weights on the back there's like bunch
of different weights back here
but right now I'm using a mouse but the
only reason I'm using a mouse right now
because my graphics tablet I have a
Wacom Intuos 4 into us for pro so I use
a pen and the whole reason I'm doing
this is because it saves you on that
carpal tunnel and if graphic artists
need to use their wrists for the rest of
their lives
then why risk it why use a mouse yeah
this is the tablet that I usually use I
love it it's smaller I don't need a huge
one and it's not one of the ones where
you see the screen on here it's just you
know like a little pen tablet deal that
connects to your computer it's you can
flip it around which whoever way works
best for you
it has a lot of hotkeys and special
buttons and stuff and this is what I
prefer this what I use at work at
corridor it's usually what I use at home
but recently the latest update on this
thing kind of janked out my system or
rather it made it difficult to use so
I'm waiting for the next update on this
which should probably come out and who
knows it's like every few weeks or so
but yeah usually I'm using this guy the
Intuos for pro Wacom tablet with a
little pen you know and the eraser even
works too
you store it in this little guy but yeah
invest in your health right why risk
breaking your wrists when you don't need
to but good question CG studio and thank
you for the super chat it is much much
appreciated all right it looks like
terminator Mouse dude living in 2189
heck yeah man christian or christian
asks does it speed up or slow down your
workflow with the tablet i'm thinking
about switching my mouse to this please
do it it speeds up my workflow I love it
I use it a whole whole bunch man so yeah
um okay let's grab some of this grass
this stuff looks gross and it's all yeah
let's just take these six here heck
let's take all of it but that's stuff in
the back let's copy it and let's go back
into our scene and paste it okay and
give give octane and c40 a second here
it's gonna think about what it's like no
it's done thinking okay we want to
scatter this stuff right so let's hop
out of our camera view we can even throw
a protection tag on our camera to make
sure we don't get
you know we don't move it boom throw
protection attack on there so now you
can't move the camera alright and if you
do move accidentally move the camera and
you want to get back to the exact point
you were in if you hit control shift Z
you'll start undoing camera moves and
only camera moves and the same is true
for control shift Y if you want to redo
things right so that is a huge
time-saver um all right so let's scatter
this grass across our scene okay so
actually I just need those those three
right there plus maybe this guy yeah
we don't need any of the other ones
accidentally grab some duplicates so
let's just get rid of those twos and
ones there so we have our four types of
grass we want to scatter across this
muddy plane so what we'll do is you know
you saw me use a c4d scatter but I'm
gonna use an octane scatter on this one
so yeah it's just a little octane
scatter I'm gonna select all four of
these drop it into octane scatter and it
works basically the same and let's do
let's select what we want to scatter it
across so we will select sorry guys I'm
blanking a little bit we'll select our
plane here that's what we want
so with octane scatter selected your
distribution you'll want to scatter
across the surface and you'll want to
scatter across the surface of looking
for something it's your plane three and
let's just rename that to ground while
we're at it right
it looks like nothing's really happening
so let's go back to octane scatter let's
set the count to like 5000 so you see in
our viewport we have 5000 little lines
right and that is should be scattering
our stuff but it looks like everything
is laying down for some reason and I
think that's because the axis of all
these things are they off yeah they're
off you see right here this green arrow
is the y-axis in octane so green why it
should be going up and this is the
lamest thing in the world but the way I
remember it
why is the y-axis goes up because you're
gonna say Yahoo when you freaking jump
up in the air and when you come back
down you're gonna say Yahoo cuz that's
what people say when you go up and you
go down is Yahoo and it starts with a y
and that's the dumbest lamest way I
remember it so just make sure your Y
axis is pointed up okay
and right now it's not it's set to
negative 90s so the way to fix that is
if you just and I believe the cases
that's the case for all these mm-hmm
select all four of them and hit L or
select a little access tool over here
change the negative 90 to zero and that
will recorrect all of that so that your
y-axis your little Yahoo axis is
pointing straight up and now when you
check it BAM Sun is gonna work it's just
gonna freakin work yeah let's go back
into our octane camera and you can see
it's scattered across the ground and
let's just render region here and you
can see that there so basically it
everything's uniform again let's some
scatter a lot more around here so let's
do 20,000 scatters across the ground and
it's a little bit it's a little
bright for me so let's change the color
of it in a second but first let's select
octane scatter and it's cool because you
can actually use the cinema 4d effectors
on octane scatter as well so I'm gonna
do a random effector and it doesn't
automatically get linked like it would
if you had selected a c4d cloner and
linked it so you're gonna have to click
the octane scatter go to the effectors
tab on the far right and drag that
random modifier in let's go back to the
random modifier let's turn off position
because it's already being randomly
scattered positionally we want to check
rotation right and we want to make sure
that the plants aren't all facing the
same way like little 2d cards we want to
rotate them randomly on I believe the
y-axis is what we want so let's um get
out of camera view and just make sure
things are being rotated properly so yes
it should be the first option we'll set
that to 360 that means everything's
gonna be randomly rotated at least by a
full 360 degree deal moving on let's
just do like 20 degree by 20 degrees so
the plants all have a little bit of like
tilt to them you know randomly tilted
this way and that maybe set that to 35
35 and 360 if we go 720 I doubt that
I'll do much but because 360 is already
enough so now if we want to scatter the
plants a bit more randomly we can do a
couple things so if you go to octane
scatter and you go to distribution and
scroll down here to position you can
load in a noise map and if you go to
that noise map you click that and you
set the contrast to 100 basically what
it's gonna do and let's let's even go
step further global scale it's set
mm it's going to randomly distribute
it's gonna use the noise map to
basically say whatever is black there's
not gonna be anything there but whatever
is white
we'll put stuff there so it's a it's an
added way to randomize the distribution
of the things you're scattering okay
let's take our global scale up to 2000
and render region because we're just
looking at the ground here CG studio
thanks again for the super chat man from
India I've always wanted to visit India
I will visit India he says you and
render my favorite favourites in
corridor great fan of your work
thank you so much I very much appreciate
all of your contributions to this thing
man it's been insane and yeah we'll see
if we can't get rent on the next stream
I think that'd be awesome
rent is incredible very talented let's
uh let's take these let's take the
plants here and scale them up so I'm
[ __ ] tea and just dragging and
scaling up and let's um take the noise
map we obviously don't need to go in
tents with the you know 100% contrast
but let's take the noise and just change
it to something else like Pok so what
does pakka look like well just like
little little bits but is it working
properly cuz I feel like this should
just give you a little bit based on that
noise map right
yeah it should just scatter it maybe
maybe it's because the global scale
needs to be turned way up 3,000 global
scale
just make sure I'm doing this right
position shader yeah I'm using the noise
map there
[Music]
you know but that looks pretty nice I
think I take the countdown to 15,000 and
stead and let's go into the actual grass
texture and just make it a little bit
darker
so we'll take defuse here and we'll
throw a color correction node right on
there and let's just render region right
and we'll just set the brightness to 0.5
and already that's doing a lot that's
doing a lot yeah it's cool it breaks up
the ground texture and also gives us a
bit more detail in like our horizon line
it's not flat you know there's actually
some stuff going on there so I think
that's great and if you wanted to go
next level you could add another thing
to your octane scatter right you could
add like taller grass different kinds of
dead grass you can really go to town on
that so that might be something I do
like later tonight or something is just
really bring this to the max and yeah
let's see if we can't see if we can't
get this ground a bit more wet so I'm
gonna go into the mud material here and
remove the roughness Channel and last
time I did this it crashed so sweet that
time it worked I'm also gonna remove the
respect the specular and let's render a
region to see what its gonna look like
man you guys are awesome we still have
60 viewers that has been consistent the
entire time you guys are in on this
we've been going for three and a half
hours how's everybody doing
thumbs up thumbs up if you guys are
doing alright if you're surviving if you
need to leave soon that's totally cool I
understand okay you guys are saying you
can't see much the water
that's a good point that's a good point
because there's a lot of there's a lot
of stuff breaking up the water that's
all the dead grass and stuff so I think
there might be a way to bring that back
to bring that back in so I'm gonna do a
little test here
roben asks where I post my finished
renders and I do that on my Instagram
that's at underscore poni shirt
underscore it's in the chat there for
you guys unfortunately someone has poni
sure and I had to put underscores on the
end of mine so that's where I posted on
my photography and all my renders
alright so maybe we can cheat this a
little bit let's um make an octane light
and move it over rotate it around point
it down move it up and we'll select the
area light node go to visibility and
check camera visibility and obviously
it's way too bright so let's just take
that down to like 10 scaled across
okay what's the best way to do this
looks so crazy
was really interesting basically I'm
just trying to brighten up like the
portion that is being reflected and like
by shining an area light into the fog
it's using it's basically bouncing that
light back and now how to make something
only visible and reflections that's an
interesting question
[Music]
visibility shadow visibility general
visibility now I wonder if I'd just be
able to like turn this way down like to
one and point it just right right at the
water or something
Thomas thanks for joining in really
appreciate you I hope you have a good
night's sleep hope it's not too scary
for you sweet dreams
alright let's try and wrap this thing up
pretty soon here I definitely agree with
you guys that the water we kind of lost
a little bit of water and I'd like to
bring that back and maybe instead of
using a specular material I'm gonna use
a glassy material like we originally did
and set it to set it to zero so it's
completely reflective but I think that's
a bit much so we can take the maybe the
opacity to 0.5
I think that works point six and we'll
take the defuse and make it like a like
a nasty dark green or something
maybe it's the specular we're looking
for like a brownish gross Brown Oh ruff
I lied let's take back to white
but that feels pretty good to me like
you can control it now so we have like
just control the opacity on the ground
there so we got our reflections back
that's cool yeah um I guess what's next
we add the head we can probably make the
tree darker if we go to the willow tree
and if we just give it that black
texture Oh am I gonna crash
my crashing what's happening that'll ya
hopefully if we if we make the willow
tree give it just the black texture
it'll show up a little bit darker but
honestly you can just do that in
Photoshop you can tweak that in
Photoshop
Oh Joe says it's not that scary anymore
you should try to light the water from
behind the camera um I don't know I
don't know if I disagree I think it
looks pretty pretty creepy
I'm so torn cuz like the vertical one
looks cool the vertical composition
looks cool but I also I'm so I'm a
sucker for you know for the horizontal
as well now vertical looks cooler
vertical certainly
this is awesome CG studio back with a
super chat appreciate you man he says
maybe you can add an emission material
on a plane then you can uncheck
visibility on diffuse if you want to
light only affecting the water okay let
me think about this for a second maybe
you can add an emission material on a
plane okay so you you use a plane as
like a light then you can uncheck
visibility on diffuse so it's just yeah
it's just like an invisible light
basically if you want a light only
affecting the water
I wonder oh man okay what if it the
scene was a nighttime with the light
source coming from a flashlight as if
someone is exploring at night with
first-person POV that is creepy okay
that's creepy yeah let me try um let's
try that let's try that and the light
the light and the water is interesting
too um let's just see what that looks
like real quick and then let's turn it
nighttime and see if that looks cool
okay
so this is with a light in the water
hmm it's not that's not working for some
reason
I think it's because I need to change
the water back to a specular material
and I think that would crunch up the
render times hard super hard let me let
me turn at night and let me see if that
does anything so basically what I'm
going to do is I'll change the octane
sky here I'm gonna duplicate the octane
sky because I like what we have I'll
name this octane sky gray and then let's
use the new one and switch it back to a
texture let's go HDRI link we're gonna
use their HDI browser and actually
greyscale gorilla came out with or is
coming out with a really really cool
HDR iPAQ and it's a space pack and I
think this actually might be pretty
sweet for a night scene so let's just
grab I don't know let's grab a space
evening sky and see what this does to
our scene here okay let's turn on this
area light and move it down and let's
turn the octane area light into an IES
light and we're going to select an IES
profile to give us kind of like a
flashlight look let's change the power
back to 108 this thing in the right
direction and scale it properly let's
scale this thing down
and let's move the light just behind the
camera so it looks like you know
someone's holding a flashlight
and this is very this is very
reminiscent of like a beep will render
he actually just did like a anyone
called power up with Luigi and he this
one was like Pikachu and the sewers and
the caves and it's so freakin creepy but
let's switch to DL it's gonna make this
process a lot faster direct lighting
let's turn off the post-processing and
oh that is that is like legit terrifying
let's crank up the brightness on this
guy
that's so creepy let's go to the HDRI
and I'm just wanna make sure it's
working it's very dark so let's switch
it to a daylight one and see if it's
working okay and I don't think it's
working so what I'll do here because
it's a little too dark I think it's
awesome
but I also think let's see I also think
it'd be nice if we could see that tree
and maybe maybe we can throw another
light up here and light the tree from
underneath
well but I was supposed to I was
supposed to duplicate that let's bring
it back
and I feel like the only thing you need
is like something actually in the
background you know and let's see if we
can do do I keep not copying this light
what's going on let's let's actually
copy this light why is it okay hold on
that's so weird
or you could backlight the tree actually
let's do that that's going to be awesome
if we backlight the tree so let's turn
this light round 180
let's make it a little larger you know
and I think if we can get our hgri
working that's kind of what I'm going
for to backlight the tree with but you
guys a good idea if we hop back into the
camera and you can now see how the scene
is a little bit backlit and give it a
second because when you go when you go
nighttime when you turn the lights off
for some reason I don't know it just
starts crunching things down and I think
it's the fog
honestly the fog is not helping us with
our render times here but we're getting
a volumetric effect with the light and
that's the way we're lumen ating the air
particles behind the tree and without
the fog we wouldn't be getting this
backlight effect
CGT studio thank you thank you for your
contribution on this stream it's much
appreciated man I hope you get a good
night's sleep
but yeah you guys can see this this
renders just taking eons so I'm gonna go
back to the original look here I'm gonna
get our fog going again and we can even
tone down this color here to like more
of a dark vibe then maybe turn it blue
and that'll kind of give us like a fake
night look something like this where you
can still see the fog you get the fog
but you also get the night vibes at the
same time and it's very similar to
there's a level in Resident Evil 4 when
you go back to the village and you hit
the cemetery and I'm getting vibes right
now from that very similar but yes I I
agree I did like the original hazy look
so I'm gonna I'm gonna stick with that I
like this very much
very very much so I think I'm gonna have
to bounce out here guys but um I really
appreciate everybody I'm gonna keep
working on this thing I'll work on it
tonight I'm just I'm gonna add the heads
whether they're skulls or those heads
that we made I'm gonna do switch up some
sticks a couple more sticks and stuff
I'm gonna hop in a Photoshop and edit
this thing a little bit work with the
contrast and work with the the vignette
and make sure that's looking nice
anything else I might add something in
the water like a tire or something very
subtle and then I think those crows
flying away would be a nice touch so
yeah yeah that's that's the vibe guys
this was a fun one this was a really
really fun one
this is the second time I have made an
image on the stream that will be
uploaded to my Instagram you guys want
to see the final just follow me on
instagram i'm at underscore poni sure
underscore that's I mean you guys are on
the YouTube page here it's pwn I SH er
with underscores on the front in the
back so you guys will see this final
image there and I'm gonna add some film
grin to it and make it I really what
what my goal is with these renders is
not to do something that's totally fake
and out of out of the realm of realistic
I want to make renders that look like
photos like I take like I took a shot
with like my film camera or something
because I'm really into film photography
and you'll see a lot of that on my
Instagram and on my website it's noise
grain and light calm once again I know I
had the super chat and enabled it and
you guys have been killing it on this
stream I also have my website if you
guys want to actually get a physical
thing shipped from me to you guys I have
these shots here
and you guys can kind of see where I get
my inspiration from you know like this
kind of setup here very foggy very
peaceful and I want my renders to look
like this you know I want it to look
like a like a photograph so that's kind
of what I'm going with
with my photography right is like you
know this is kind of vibe here but uh
thank you guys thank you guys so much
for everything I really appreciate
everyone and I look forward to next
Saturday we'll come back at it and maybe
we'll do a render challenge where we
have like two hours we have assets that
are pre uploaded to Google Drive or
something and we'll you know we'll do a
render challenge together and if melanie
has a sketch pad she'll draw something
you know but whatever you know you guys
just keep it up you know keep your
passion going throughout the week
practice your passion at least once an
I'm sorry practice your passion at least
once a day for an hour and I promise you
you will get better at it much faster
much much much faster but yeah I really
appreciate you guys this has been the
first chat where like the the freaking
the super chat blew up I thought was so
cool
you guys are awesome so yeah let's keep
it up let's keep going let's make
something cool together join the discord
channel if you have not already the link
is in the description of this video here
I have my Spotify
ambient playlist you can join that and
do some super atmospheric renders or
yeah you can do super atmospheric
renders with some atmospheric music what
else is in there I also have like a
movie reference frame package where I
saved out all my favorite stills from my
favorite movies and you guys can use
those as reference for lighting or
cinematography composition all that good
stuff I think that's everything thanks
again and I'll see you guys next time on
the next chat peace